so what would be your your commentary
for the semi sweet bro this semi sweet i
think it's a fantastic chocolate really
it's definitely one of my favorites just
because it's it has these very
distinctive sorta funny notes and also
has some melad like food folders also
has some cherry cherry notes as well it
really reminds me of sort of a dessert
wine I Saturn or something like that so
I really really enjoy that is there a
parent I don't know if there is I
imagine somebody's probably thought
about that's Harry with chocolate with
one that you can pair anything with
chocolate and a good one where there's I
haven't explored that as much i'm sort
of traditional and I just sort of like
the Gator dropping on it so I'd
appreciate it and also appreciate one
but at the same time I think there's
some fantastic pairings with reserve
wines that I've just been started
getting into there's a lot of really
complementary flavors that go as well
you're talking about scotch earlier
right Scotch has there's great potential
for parents scotch and dark child
especially some of the darker shopping
genera looks so I have it was sounds
like an excuse to have Scotch in
chocolate so for the people who are
watching because a lot of people who go
to my blog are interested in travel
juras Dallas of course so Debbie did you
travel much in 2007 I yeah 2007 I travel
to prevent what were so the set of the
highlights hi well I was Holly I was in
Honduras which was fantastic full great
check out projects going on there with
some farmers and some development
projects helping farmers really
have access to superior genetics a
flavored plant so sort of helping
encourage them to plant the types of
cacao that are going to produce the
complex flavors that you have here so
I'm gonna buy the the terror are so to
speak that the ideal climate environment
that encourage them to use seeds that
will flourish an entirely yeah and what
I'm just talking about Tara I mean I
think she also terroirs this very snobby
term used in Napa and Sonoma which is
close by to describe what would be the
soil in the climate yeah sort of the
general environment a general
environment in which you can plant
cultivate certain types of wine but
we'll use that directive okay well
anyway they're apparently what if one of
the exciting things about being in a job
at industry right now is that there's so
much research yet to be done so there
are there are so many questions yet
unanswered is really you know what is
the relationship between soil type and
the end flavor of a karate and even
looking at genetics understanding
now that affects the flavor so much of
this stuff is really sentencing studying
this stuff so it's exciting to sort of
be working with us right now that's cool
so Honduras and on Doris I was in ghana
ghana which are sold she was fantastic
hard to get things together his story
with that I know somebody's had a lot of
trouble getting clippings but i guess
that has got a hair there must be all
right so you what he got it Connor
Connor was amazing there's a lot of
codes I think it's the second largest
producer football maybe the third
everybody after the Ivory Coast so I
realizes the number one when I proposed
to the number one huge West Africa I
think
some somewhere over sixty-five percent a
lot of those cocos yeah and so for those
of you you fact-checkers watching this
is a very informal conversation so go do
your own homework and go to Wikipedia
and get something 10 times less accurate
or you can actually go somewhere online
and get the proper statistics but this
is an informal conversation among
friends eating chocolate very cool so
how does someone apply to have a job
testing chocolate and travel around the
world how do you how did you end up
about a project all right sure I
actually studied botany and I just got
into tropical tropical botany and became
enthralled with cocoa plant which is all
so did you apply or did you bump into
Sona today you should be I actually I
took some I took some trips down through
Central and South America and worked on
cocoa plantations and and just learned a
lot of learned as much as i could and
try to I've always been into chocolate
and into food and I work for publicly
owned companies
down here in sharpie cool all right well
I guess we can go take a look now this
is top secret stuff so we may not be
bringing the filming apparatus with us
but take a look at the factory and then
continue the conversation mmm lists have
been left alone in the tub to beggary I
know look alone and Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory this is delicious this
milk almond delicious word is that is
very common people to pick up one of
these take a small bite and finish the
entire bar with sitting delicious really
good all right then so we're looking at
the nibs all right so as we're talking
about earlier nibs are really just these
cocoa beans these are raw cocoa beans
that come straight out of a burlap sack
so a farmer grows as beans down in the
farm and the tropics ferments them dries
them puts them in a burlap sack they you
know hop onto a onto a container ship
and they end up here in the port of
oakland and and they come to our factory
we get the burlap sacks we open them up
and then we go through and roast them
for about an hour and then week there's
a machine called a widower that just
takes the show up and then we end up
with these with these little things here
called nibs and these are just this is
this is just essentially the the inside
cotyledon of this list of the seed so
and this is really the core of chocolate
so when you look at these numbers when
you say you know eighty-two percent
cacao seventy percent 62 what's up what
that is saying is how much of that of
this chocolate comes from this this
cocoa nib right and you can actually
chew on this you can actually eat these
absolutely absolutely they have and when
we do our product development testing we
actually don't add any sugar we'll all
we do is we just take these nibs we
grind them up in sort of a small
beefy coffee grinder and we just when we
make an unsweetened pace no kidding cool
and then we just taste it would you just
take a little bit yeah yeah oh yeah I
guess something I'm using my fingers
like a caveman and the spoon is right
here fingers are okay junnar what do you
think so each of these is very
distinctive is that the madagascar yeah
so the Madagascar has a character very
characteristically sort of sour yelling
stuff citrusy yeah this one here is that
is the Trinidad the Trinidad tends to
have sort of a fruity spice to it it
often reminds me of this sort of an
apple apple cinnamon flavor and then
here we have the Guarani which is
characteristic sort of big cherry fruit
but also sort of a hazard spiciness as
well now keep in mind every single one
of these beans is going to have a
different flavor right and therefore
every one of these nibs has a
distinctive flavor so that's why we
actually when we're actually doing the
trials we will grind them up and have a
bigger quantity for the same ring but it
is fun to eat the niche they're great
sprinkled on ice cream really mmm excuse
the ice cream they're actually they're
actually perfect bring a demo putting
together the list for saturday so we've
got scotch we've got chocolate nibs and
ice cream nice and a salad too no
kidding Wow nibs on salad delicious
you